last night at San Diego Comic Cons Hall
H panel Marvel officially revealed phase
four of the MCU how's it going everybody
it's Warren and last night was the
moment that we had all been waiting for
for a really long time now and it did
not disappoint last night I did a video
talking about just the reveal of the
face for Slade but in this video I'm
going to talk about everything that was
said about the movies that were revealed
and everything that we know about phase
4 and yes that does include the
announcement of the Fantastic Four and
the x-men coming into the MCU so I'll
break down everything that we know about
phase 4 also a reminder I'm doing a
giveaway at 500,000 subscribers I'm
giving away an Xbox one or a ps4 winner
gets to choose and some Marvel Legends
items including Captain America shield
iron man's helmet the Infinity Gauntlet
and more if you'd like to enter for your
chance to win all you have to do is be
subscribed to my channel like this video
and comment down below with your
thoughts and your favorite superhero or
villain I'm also giving away an Infinity
Gauntlet on Instagram if you want to
follow me at cosmic war in 13 so first
things first about this phase 4 revealed
it's only a partial reveal they only
revealed up until 2021 2022 was not
revealed yet the rest of it will most
likely be revealed at d23 which is next
month so if you're disappointed that
movies like Ant Man 3 or guardians of
the galaxy vol 3 weren't announced
tonight don't worry they still could be
a part of phase 4 but let's talk about
the phase 4 that was revealed the first
movie that was revealed was the Eternals
now we knew that the Eternals was coming
there was a ton of reports about the
movie about casting we knew it was
coming it just wasn't confirmed but now
not only is it confirmed and officially
announced we know who the cast is and
the cast is absolutely incredible
the cast is Angelina Jolie Richard
Madden Camille Nanjiani
Lauren red Liffe Brian Tyree Henry Salma
Hayek Lea McHugh and Dawn Lee and the
movie will be directed by Chloe Zhou
Angelina Jolie is going to be playing
the role of Tina and Richard Madden is
going to be plain Icarus then we have
Salma Hayek playing the role of a jack
Camille Nanjiani is going to be playing
Kingo Brian Tyree Henry is going to be
playing fast dose
and Lia McHugh is going to be playing
sprite then we have Lauren rid laughs
who is going to be playing the role of
mockery and Lauren rid laughs will be
the first deaf actor to be in the MCU
the Eternals were created by the
Celestials who are God like a beam so
this movie is going to be fantastic plus
you add the stacked cast this movie is
going to be simply amazing and it comes
out November 6 2020 the next
announcement from phase 4 at San Diego
comic-con was the Falcon and Winter
Soldier series the Falcon and Winter
Soldier series is going to become in
fall of 2020 and at San Diego comic-con
they did reveal the return of Baron Zemo
so it seems like salmon lucky are going
to be going up against an old Captain
America enemy the two actors Anthony
Mackie and Sebastian Stan did tease the
fact that both of them will probably be
wielding Captain America shield in the
series they passed back Captain America
shield on stage back and forth between
each other while laughing and it would
make sense that they would both carry
the shield at one point in time because
they were both best friends with Captain
then we finally got the reveal of
shang-chi and we learned that the title
is going to be called shang-chi and the
legend of the ten rings now this is
really big news because it confirms that
the Mandarin not the fake Mandarin from
Iron Man 3 but the real Mandarin from
the Iron Man comics is going to be in
the MCU and we finally have an official
cast we have Sima Leo who is going to be
playing shang-chi Aquafina who is going
to be playing a role and Tony Leung who
is going to be playing a role as well
Shang Chi is going to be the first movie
with an Asian superhero as the main
character and it comes out on February
12th of 2021 we then have the Wanda and
vision series that is going to be coming
to Disney Plus in spring 2020 now we've
got a major reveal about the Wanda and
vision series that connects with the new
Doctor Strange movie that we're going to
be getting so I'll touch more about this
when I talk about Doctor Strange 2 but
they did cast Teyana Parris who was
going to be playing Monica Rambeau in
the Wanda and vision series next that
was revealed for phase 4 is the Loki
series that is coming exclusively to
Disney Plus in spring of 2021 now we did
learn something very major about the
Loki series is plot with
learned that the show is going to start
right when Loki escapes with the
tesseract in 2012 and Avengers in game
when the Avengers go back in time this
was one of the biggest questions about
Avengers endgame when Loki grabs the
tesseract and escapes where does he go
what does he do and does he create an
alternate timeline also does he somehow
manage a way to get to other timelines
could he end up in the main timeline
again this is what the Disney + Loki
series is going to be all about what
Loki did when he escaped with the
tesseract then we have the movie that a
lot of people have been waiting for
Doctor Strange in the multiverse of
madness now this movie is going to be
insanely huge for many many reasons for
starters they said that this film is
going to be the first scary film of the
MCU but it's still going to be pg-13
nightmare is confirmed to be the villain
and the Scarlet Witch is confirmed to be
in Doctor Strange 2 as well so the
events that take place in the Wanda and
vision series will affect and go into
Doctor Strange in the multiverse of
madness and as it says in the title this
film is going to officially address the
multiverse the multiverse was first
mentioned and addressed in Doctor
Strange number 1 and it seems like
they're going to dive even deeper into
that and Doctor Strange in the
multiverse of madness and it makes sense
that he would and it makes sense that
they are calling it multiverse of
madness because after avengers endgame
the avengers created many multiple
timelines so the multiverse is probably
super thrown off with all these
different timelines then we have the
Disney what-if series that was announced
and this is going to be a really
interesting series it's going to be the
first animated series that exists in the
MCU and they revealed at San Diego
comic-con that Jeffrey Wright is going
to be voicing The Watcher in this series
they also confirmed that all the actors
in the MCU are going to be voicing their
characters that appear in the what-if
series now for those of you who don't
really know what the what-if series is
going to be about it comes from the
what-if comics and it's basically just
like it sounds it explores stories of
what if this would have happened for
example one of the first stories that
they're thinking about doing for the
what-if series is what if Peggy Carter
was Captain America so it's going to be
really cool to see these very different
animated series in the MCU and that's
going to launch
on Disney Plus in the summer of 2021
then we have the official announcement
of the Hawkeye series coming to Disney
Plus this was rumored for a very long
time but nobody knew if it was official
well of course it was announced at San
Diego comic-con so it is official and
they officially announced that Kate
Bishop will be in the Hawkeye series
Hawkeye will be training Kate Bush up in
the comics Kate Bishop is the first
female to take on the mantle of Hawkeye
and she is also in the Young Avengers so
maybe Marvel is setting her up to be in
the Young Avengers one day in the MCU
the Hawkeye series will be coming to
Disney Plus and fall of 2021 we then
have one of the most exciting
announcements if not the most exciting
announcement of the face for slate that
is Thor for Thor love and thunder the
biggest reveal for Thor love and thunder
is that Natalie Portman is going to be
returning as Jane Foster and Jane Foster
is going to be playing lady Thor who can
lift Mele near this is huge this is
something that people have been wanting
to see for a very very long time now
it's one of the most popular comics out
there and it's going to be really
awesome to see on screen finally it was
also announced that Tessa Thompson's
character Valkyrie is in fact LGBTQ and
is looking for a queen as she is the
king of Asgard now Thor love and thunder
will be hitting the theaters November
5th 2021 and then the last movie that
was revealed for phase 4 was the Black
Widow movie Black Widow was the only
face for movie that they showed footage
for at San Diego Comic Con and in this
footage it was confirmed that taskmaster
is indeed the villain of the Black Widow
movie we also now have confirmation of
who the cast is the cast is going to be
david harbor from stranger things
florence pew OT [ __ ] vanilla and rachel
wise it has also been confirmed that the
black widow movie will take place after
the events of civil war after Civil War
Natasha
returns to Budapest so it seems like
we're finally going to see what happened
with NAT and Clint in Budapest and that
was it for the phase four movies that
they had on the screen however they went
on to announce several more films right
after Black Widow Kevin Feige announced
that a blade movie is officially in the
war
and revealed the logo for it and they
announced that mahir shala Ali will be
playing the role of blade who is
absolutely perfect for the part blade is
an awesome superhero and fans have been
wanting a remake of blade for a really
really long time now so everybody is
really excited about the announcement of
blade there is no official release date
for it yet but it has been officially
announced by Kevin Feige the president
of Marvel Studios Kevin Feige also
announced that we are in fact getting a
Fantastic Four movie and that the x-men
are in fact coming to the MCU soon
before the panel ended Kevin Feige got
on stage and said that the Fantastic
Four
mutants blacc panther2 guardians of the
galaxy vol 3 and Captain Marvel 2 are
all happening soon and keep in mind this
is only a part of the phase 4 reveal
they still have to reveal the 2022 dates
so perhaps we could get the reveal of
these movies at d23 which is next month
and in an interview with IGN right after
the San Diego Comic Con Hall H panel
Kevin Feige
was asked about calling the x-men
mutants in the panel he was asked if
they are not going the traditional route
of the x-men in the MCU and he replied
with he uses the term x-men and mutants
interchangeably so he basically means
x-men but then he said whatever we do
with the x-men is going to be quite
different than what you've seen before
this of course is great news because
people haven't been too pleased with the
x-men lately but now that Kevin Feige is
in charge of all of the x-men I'm sure
he will do them all justice
so the x-men and the Fantastic Four are
finally going to be making their way
into the MCU it is confirmed by the
president of Marvel Studios himself
Kevin Feige and that is it for all the
reveals of last night's San Diego Comic
Con Hall H panel and the reveal of phase
4 of the MCU what did you all think
about the movies and the shows that were
revealed and what do you think is going
to be further revealed - probably at the
d23 event but what do you think the next
part of phase 4 is going to be like be
sure to comment down below with your
thoughts and also be sure to comment
with your favorite superhero or villain
like this video and subscribe to my
channel for your chance to win a xbox
one or a ps4 and a Marvel Legends item
also follow me on Instagram for a chance
to win and
finiti gauntlet as always thank you all
so much for watching
woof woof